I read your tweets and you tweeted
recently I wish I was as hairless as
those Olympic divers why did you why did
you tweet that whoa think about okay I
have a hairy chest there's a story to
this and my you know I used to manscape
because I live there is a story I
started god what didn't you would
manscape I don't know they just trimming
it or you actually make you loopy Airy
forms a little dinosaurs swimming I was
trimming I was trimming my this is this
a dinosaur source you took you have to
use like simple English words with me
okay okay
you make dinosaur with Jess anyway so I
manscaped my chest because but then I
got married and my wife said you know
don't manscape anymore it's the only
manly thing about you is your hairy
chest so I kept I kept my hairy chest
and and then I would look at these
Olympic divers and here's my problem not
a problem but here's my observation
mm-hmm
if I was to shave my chest it would be
or I don't know how are your chest is
but I'm presuming you have some hair on
your chest
yes yeah break copper brush fire working
raging inferno moving its way north
apparently they like sorry I was I
thinking about is yes down south so so
anyway this Olympic divers they would so
if they were to shave that chest
wouldn't it be like red and bumpy and
like you don't I mean like if they had a
lot of hair in the chest but they it
looks like smooth like not even waxed
almost like the chlorine has rubbed off
the hair on their chest is that
something that just Corinne have any
effect on a friend of mine told me that
that's what happens and it sounds like a
story that's made up but I don't know
whatever it is if I was more about this
friend of yours he's saying if you jump
in a pool and swim around a lot all the
hair falls off your body yeah he says
the friction caused and the chlorine
causes if I was to be an Olympic diver
my hair would get in the way that's how
much hair I would have I would lose
seconds maybe minutes diving into the
pool be like you are swimming with a
blanket wrap around you it's like a big
black body parachute that's to me well
that's good you fall on the water a
print sounds like it inflates and help
oh yeah I can never drown
I've never drone you'll just float in
the sea forever till help comes exactly